So I am introducing,
um,
all but degree of as,
as the chief science officer off the Central Research Foundation and he is,
uh,
a major false in aging research and I'm very excited to hear this talk.
[inaudible]
all right.
Thank you all for coming.
I'm glad to see from any of your hair.
Uh,
yeah,
the only five bucks left over there.
That's about 21 when we came into the room.
So
hurry.
Uh,
but yeah,
I don't,
I'm happy to find them if you're really wanting to be a terribly fanboy kind of
person later on.
Um,
um,
all right.
So yes,
I saw,
I've got an hour so I'm going to cry and tell you as much as I can about what we
do at we fixed foundation and why and why it's important and why you should be
supporting it and how you can support it.
And there were various ways he can do that.
Um,
I'm going to start by giving you a really top level idea because I know
obviously most of you don't have very much in the way of biology.
Craning I'm going to start by saying why I think this is such an important
problem.
Um,
this part of the world by area is really the epicenter of the effective altruism
movement,
the movement that really focuses on rationally determining what is the best way
to spend money on,
um,
you know,
on humanitarian causes,
what gets the best bang for the buck.
And of course people try to figure out,
you know,
what the amount of suffering is that it's caused by this or that problem and,
um,
uh,
what,
um,
what it would cost us to do something about that.
And they're trying to figure it out from there.
And,
uh,
a lot of this comes down to the trade off between mean and variants.
In other words,
between understanding how much good you can do and understanding the uncertainty
as regard how much good you can do.
So high risk,
high reward,
um,
then,
uh,
endeavors like,
um,
you know,
pioneering technology often get a kind of,
the short,
the short end of the,
of the stick when it comes to effective altruism because they don't really,
um,
you know,
offer the confidence,
the certainty that people like to see with regard to knowing that what they're
doing is actually beneficial.
And the extreme end of that is a of that spectrum is the situation where you
don't know whether the problem is solvable at all,
whether it's not just high risk,
high reward,
it could be 100% risk.
In other words,
you know,
zero chance of success,
however,
there will,
however large the reward would be.
And now the problem with that is,
you know,
zero times anything is still zero.
So,
um,
you know,
however valuable they,
uh,
the,
the goal might be you wouldn't really want to go that.
And,
um,
certainly the comparison between the defeat of aging versus various other,
you know,
seriously high profile,
um,
major issues today.
The ones that I'm listing on this,
on the,
on the slide,
you know,
that's quite a contrast.
Before it was biology.
So I used to work in artificial intelligence research and the fundamental reason
that I did so was that I didn't think that work with a terribly good thing.
You know,
I think it's a great shame that people have to spend so much of their time doing
stuff that they wouldn't do unless they were being paid for it.
And so I decided I wanted to fix that with automation.
And um,
and I worked in that area,
it actually in software verification for several years before I discovered that
the obviously much more serious problem of aging was actually being worked on
very,
very little indeed by biologists.
And I thought that was a bit crap really.
So I switched fields.
Um,
but when I switched fields,
I realized,
in fact,
actually this was actually part of the reason why I switched fields.
I realized that the people who were working on this,
which were as I say,
only a very small minority of biologists word going about it in a rather
unimpressive way.
They weren't really going about it as engineers.
They weren't really,
you know,
breaking down the problem in a structured manner the way that a programmer might
do.
And,
um,
so that's what I tried to do.
And I started here,
I started with a question we'll look 200 years ago,
even in the wealthiest countries,
more than one third of babies would die before the age of one more than a third.
And of course in the rest of early life,
you know,
and other alternative and you know,
there will be a lot of death,
childbirth especially of course.
And we've pretty much entirely eliminated,
eliminated that now in the industrialized world.
And of course we're doing very well in that direction in the developing world
to,
and we've done it by really elementary means just by figuring out the hygiene
was a good idea.
And by,
you know,
um,
elementary medicines like vaccines and antibiotics and of course,
even mosquito nets,
you know,
this is a 20 things and they work,
they've said the most ridiculous number of lives,
but we've made virtually no progress against the ill health associated with old
age.
What's going on there?
Why is it so different?
So most people would say that this is the answer.
Don't worry,
you're not supposed to be able to read this slide.
They,
um,
the point here,
and obviously just that there's a lot of complexity and awful lot of different
things go wrong with us late in life and they go wrong,
it more or less the same time,
which means of course,
that they interact with each other,
they exacerbate each other.
The whole thing is a little bit chaotic and so most people would say,
well,
this is fundamentally what's going on there.
The real reason why Adrian has remained so hard to tackle where medicine is the
sheer complexity of the business,
the fact that there's so much going on,
it's just overwhelmed the ability of the medical research community.
Now,
there is a lot of truth in that.
That is definitely part of the problem.
But what are you going to know is that it's not the main part of the problem.
There's a more fundamental reason why aging has been hard to tackle and I'm
going to deal with what that is.
I'm going to start by defining aging.
This turned out to be actually cool.
Pretty tricky.
So Bjork is hosting this day.
I'm actually got an email this morning saying,
listen,
we don't want to fix aging.
You know,
we,
I think it's a good thing.
We want to get older and more knowledgeable and all that kind of stuff.
Of course it bloody do.
That's fairly obvious.
I mean the point of the study is that we want to get rid of the bad parts of
aging and thereby perpetuate and enhance the good parts.
So what aging and and for,
for the purposes of this talk will mean the bad parts of aging.
Aging is not something specific to biology.
You can say,
you can look at certain aspects of biology,
especially who biology.
You can say,
well there's some,
in some sense they are emergent phenomena.
You know,
consciousness.
You know Roxanne in our conscious cars are not conscious.
We knew that,
right?
But aging is actually not an emergent phenomenon.
Aging is a phenomenon that is fundamentally the same in living organisms as it
is in any manmade machine with moving parts like the car.
An airplane.
It is simply a fact of physics that any machine with moving parts is going to do
itself damage throughout its existence as an inevitable consequence of its
normal operation.
It's just a fact of physics and that damage is going to accumulate and that's
fine for a while because any machine living or not is set up to tolerate a
certain amount of damage and you know,
so.
So that's why for example,
cars worked perfectly fine for a few years and you don't have to take it into
the garage.
And it's also why humans work pretty well for a few decades.
So you don't have to take them into the hospital either.
But eventually the tolerable threshold of damage is reached and exceeded and
that's when things start to go downhill.
That's all that aging is.
And the reason I emphasize this is because there is a very widespread
misconception in society that aging is some kind of mystery,
that it's some kind of an enigmatic thing that we absolutely don't understand
and never can.
And you know,
it's somehow off limits from deferred for medicine.
It's just not correct.
This is simply a really obvious and basic thing and we just need to get out of
our heads the idea that it's in any way mysterious.
We can actually describe it industry words.
So I'm now obviously reflecting myself to biology,
to living organisms.
Metabolism is the word that biologists use to encompass all of the stuff that
the body does from one day to the next to keep us going,
keep us alive.
And unless they had,
metabolism creates damage and damage accumulates throughout life,
even starting before we're born.
And eventually there's too much damage and you get the pathologies of all day.
Now I've drawn these arrows in this rather curious way of course,
to emphasize that what we're trying to achieve with the work that we're doing to
eliminate aging is to weaken the link between metabolism and pathology,
the link between being alive and being dead.
And there are various ways in which we might go about that,
but most of them are very misguided and essentially waste of time.
And I'm going to go through a little bit of what that,
why that is before going onto what's going to work.
So what I'm showing you here is the answer that most people would give to a very
simple question.
The question in what ways can one be sick?
Can people be sick?
In other words,
give us a taxonomy of sickness.
Most people would say,
well,
okay,
those infectious diseases,
that's column one,
communicable diseases.
Then this column two is congenital genetic diseases that we are some uh,
some small proportion of us are unlucky enough to inherit.
Then con three,
there's the huge,
the main problems of Ale House in the industrialized world and we're in today,
namely of course the chronic progressive diseases of old age,
Alzheimer's,
cancer,
Atherosclerosis,
those are the big diseases these days.
And then most people would say that why out here in the scratch there somewhere
there is this other force completely different thing,
which is not like diseases at all.
This thing called aging itself,
which consists of these rather nebulous,
you know,
rather than nonspecific phenomena like frailty and you know,
Sarcopenia,
which means the loss of muscle as we get older and immunosenescence the decline
in function of the immune system.
And most people will just fail.
But these are things are so different from diseases that we might as well not
even think about them in the same way at all.
You know,
that's that they kind of,
um,
well I don't,
I mentioned earlier off limits to medicine.
Uh,
you know,
their kind of natural and inevitable and all that kind of nonsense.
This is what people say.
They say,
well there's the aging,
the diseases of old age and they did different things.
Aging is somehow universal and natural and the diseases of aging or not,
that turns out to be completely incorrect.
The correct way to classify how you can be sick.
It's shown here.
All the four columns now are the same as they were on the previous table.
But the difference is that that they black lines in a different place between
columns two and three instead of three and four.
And that is so as to emphasize two key points to key misconceptions and errors
in what people normally think.
The first error that people make that is shown by putting the black line in the
wrong place is to think that there's some kind of fundamental distinction
between column three and column four.
In other words that there really are diseases of old age and then there's aging
itself.
That's complete nonsense.
The only difference between column three and column four is semantic.
The column three consists of the aspects of aging that we've chosen to give
disease like names too and Golan fork ancestor of the aspects of aging that we
haven't.
That is all everything in either column three or column four is a consequence of
having been alive a long time.
A consequence of the accumulation of an amount of damage in the body of whatever
type that exceeds what the body is set up to tolerate.
That is all.
The other thing that putting the black line in the wrong place causes people to
think which is wrong,
is to think that column three is rather like column one if you put the black
line in the wrong place,
then your girl look for cures to things in column three.
Ways to eliminate them from the body in very much the same way that you might
eliminate tuberculosis infections or whatever.
And that again,
it all this they complete nonsense when you remember that the things in column
three or side effects of being alive.
So basically this is the route.
When you make that mistake,
you go after the pathologies of old age directly.
You try to eliminate them from the body by effectively attenuating the right
hand Arrow trying to stop the pathologies of old age from happening even despite
the fact that the things that are causing them,
namely the damage that's continuing to accumulate is talking me lighting and
it's complete nonsense.
It's obviously complete nonsense.
There's no way in the world that this could ever work because at the end of the
day,
if the damage is continuing to accumulate,
then anything that attacks and addresses the consequences of that damage in
bound to become progressively less effective as time passes.
It's just,
it's a complete misconception.
It's a category error.
And yet billions and billions of dollars are spent every year doing,
trying to do this,
trying to push,
you know,
um,
not only medical research,
but of course medical practice trying to actually make this happen.
It's,
it's insane.
Now.
I'm not the first person to point this out.
In fact,
it's been more than a hundred years now.
Excuse me.
Since people started to realize a few people started to realize that this was a
Mug's game,
that geriatric medicine was never going to work.
And that's why Gerontology came from Gerontology,
was inspired by two things.
Number one,
the realizations of geriatric medicine was never going to work.
And number two,
the observation that in the living world,
we see a great deal of variation in the rate of aging,
in the rate of accumulation of damage,
different species,
age,
very different rights,
even within a species,
different individuals age at somewhat different rights.
So the idea was while if we studied this really,
really,
really hard,
then maybe we'll eventually figure out enough about how metabolism generates
damage that we will be able to slow it down.
We'll be able to develop therapies that will somehow clean up our metabolism so
that it generates damage more slowly.
And thereby we postpone the age at which the damage reaches the intolerable
level and pathology emerges.
Great idea.
In principle,
you may,
however,
have noticed that Gerontology has not delivered the cure to aging and he wasn't.
Geriatric medicine has,
and this is why metabolism is rather complicated.
It,
I'm speaking to a bunch of coders here,
I can immediately just say,
well,
okay,
this is obviously the um,
you know,
the ultimate nightmare of uncomment it spaghetti code,
right?
This is just,
there's no way in hell that you're ever going to be able to tweak this network
so as to stop it from doing the thing you don't want it to do.
Namely the creation of damage without at the same time stopping it from doing
things you need to do to keep us alive.
It's just not going to happen.
Unintended consequences are going to happen.
So,
you know,
waste of time and unfortunately,
it took a while for Gerontologists to realize this,
but eventually they did.
I wouldn't say that by the 1970s it was pretty much established within the field
of the biology of aging that we were just not going to be able to get this
approach to work.
And so actually it went all the way to,
I mean like it became unacceptable even to talk about interventions in aging and
the grant application aging became this phenomenon,
this,
this field like you know seismology it was like,
you know,
people who study earthquakes,
they understand that um,
you know what they study is bad for you but they have no actual aspiration to
doing anything about them.
You know,
it's all about getting out of the way.
Um,
all right.
But the thing is the wisdom bit of an oversight in all of this and the oversight
was that there's a third perfectly respectable approach to dealing with this
problem,
which is what I'm going to call the maintenance approach.
Oh,
he forgot the damage repair approach and I'm trying to depict it using the same
diagram.
Essentially what we have is the goal is to weaken the link between metabolism
and pathology and the geriatrics approach to do that is to weaken the righthand
component of that process.
The the,
the link between damaging pathology,
the gerontology approaches to weaken the lefthand side,
the link between metabolism and damage,
but we don't have to do either of those.
Well,
we can do instead is go in and periodically repair the damage.
And of course what that means is that we can leave metabolism alone,
we can let metabolism generate damage at the natural rates and still it won't
reach the level of abundance that causes pathologist to a Merck.
So this is a fantastic way of doing what engineers do,
of sidestepping our ignorance of figuring out how to manipulate the system
without actually understanding it particularly well.
If we're not proposing to do anything about the rate at which damage is created,
it's fine that we have such a pitiful understanding of what metabolism actually
does and how damage is created.
Similarly,
if we're not proposing to let damage reach a level of abundance that causes
pathologists to occur,
it's fine that we don't have much understanding of the details of how those
pathologies arise from that damage and all of the interactions between the
pathologist.
So I mentioned at the beginning,
it's fine.
We can just separate the two things from each other and
it's not just common sense to you and me.
It's common sense to people in general if you think about it because hello.
Okay.
Um,
right,
because we already do it.
Remember what I said at the beginning that aging is a phenomenon of physics,
not biology.
Well,
it's a bit of physics for you.
Here's a car that is more than a hundred years old and it wasn't built that way.
The people who build this car a hundred years ago,
what has been astonished at the idea that any of the cars they were building
would last that long.
They were built to last maybe 10 years,
but it turns out house.
But we know how,
because cars are fairly simple.
We know how to do sufficiently comprehensive maintenance on cards.
Oh,
excuse me,
that we can keep them going just as well as when they were built.
And now that we've got this hundred year old car,
there is nobody who would say,
oh dear,
you know,
well we've got them out to a hundred years,
but there's no way we're going to get them to 200 that's not going to happen is
it?
Everybody knows that we can push this out as long as we like now.
So it's completely obvious from any to anyone who takes aging seriously and
doesn't actually regard it as some kind of enigma,
some kind of magic that we know what we,
this is what we should do to actually fix aging.
So,
you know,
I say this,
I said at the end of the day,
the only reason that I have to go around the world giving the bloody talks still
after all these years is because people don't want to hear this message.
It's been a long time since we realize that aging was actually rather horrible.
You know,
since the dawn of civilization,
people have had this dream of actually finding some way to maintain youth in old
age and we haven't done very well.
And the problem is of course there's a lot of people have been out there saying,
oh,
this is the solution and they've always been wrong.
So humanity has been suckered rather often,
which means of course,
that there is a great deal of reluctance to get one's hopes up.
Now,
you know,
to actually get into a mindset of saying,
well,
maybe this time it's actually going to be true.
People.
Instead they go the opposite way.
They say,
well,
okay,
let's just believe that aging really is a complete inevitability that's kind of
make up peace with it and resign ourselves and get on with our miserably short
lives and make the best of it rather than being constantly preoccupied by this
terrible thing that's going to happen.
So of course the way we do that overwhelmingly is by making up these fantasies
that pretend that it's a blessing in disguise.
You know that it's that there's some kind of good thing about aging.
I call it the pro aging trance because it's a bit like being hypnotized.
You know,
I went when I was a kid,
I went to,
when I was a student at Cambridge,
I went to a stage hypnotist show in which the hypnotist got a guy on stage and
told him,
this is actually your right elbow,
this is your last Alba.
Okay,
that's what they said.
Then he just got the guy who completely understand and believe that his elbows
were actually switched and they said,
okay,
please touch your right elbow with your left forefinger under with a whole lot
of rising and wriggling as you can imagine.
And that was all very funny.
But that wasn't the point of the,
um,
of the shark.
The point we've,
what came next?
What came next was the guy says,
he says,
okay,
you can stop now.
And the guy stops and it was just says,
right,
you couldn't do it good,
you.
And the Guy Says No.
And then the hit as he says,
why not?
And what happens then is absolutely breast tech.
What happens without fail is that the subject,
we'll get the completely unhesitating lucid,
coherent grammatical answer to the question.
He will explain why he couldn't touch his left elbow with his right fourth
finger.
And of course the actual explanation,
we'll have a hole in it,
the size of Canada,
you know,
there will be absolutely no rationality.
So the answer whatsoever.
So everybody will fall about and it will be terribly amusing,
but the fact is the subject won't have a clue what's wrong with what they're
saying.
This was,
I mean this was at the University of Cambridge,
right?
A bunch of undergraduates with very high,
you know,
academic achievements and everything like that.
And I attended their own intellect and their own rationality and the guy says
sitting there with all his friends cackling in and he just doesn't have a clue
what he's saying wrong.
So it's,
to me it's exactly like that.
You know,
it's unbelievable.
So
I realized that at this point all I've done is told you what's the common sense
approach to tackling aging well I haven't done is give you a feel for how
difficult it actually is.
Even if it's the common sense approach,
it got the author the hard right and therefore not really worth,
I'm going to go into optimistic about yet though.
That's what I need to address next.
I need to actually tell you,
I've told you that were side stepping.
Our ignorance of metabolism.
Wonderful.
And we're also sidestepping our ignorance and pathology also.
But what we're definitely not sidestepping is the complexity of the damage
itself.
We absolutely can't implement this maintenance approach unless we can
characterize what that damage is and figure out ways to repair it to eliminate
the damage and restore the structure and composition of the body at the
molecular and cellular level to something like how it was at a younger age
because that's what this is all about.
So can we actually do that?
Well,
this is really where the good news begins.
17 years ago when I first started thinking about this,
I think about the problem in this way.
Um,
the only reason why I felt optimistic was because I was able to derive a rather
concise taxonomy classification of damage.
So that's what we have on the left hand side of this table and all the seven
things you see there.
Uh,
as you can see,
very clear concrete down to earth,
real biological phenomenon,
solar,
what's that?
It's just the case of cells dying and not being automatically replaced by the
division and differentiation of other cells.
So of course if that happens then progressive with the number of cells in the
effect of dog and will decline and eventually you'll end up with not enough
cells for the organ to be able to do its job.
An example of an aspect of aging that is mainly driven by that type of damage is
Parkinson's disease.
Blake is mainly caused by the loss of a particular type of neuron called a
dopaminergic neuron in a particular part of the brain called the substantia
Nigra.
And sure enough,
um,
you know,
that's bad for you and it happens a little faster in some people than others.
And that's why some people get Parkinson's and some people don't.
But all of us have lost at least a quarter of our dopaminergic neurons that we
had as young adults.
By all day.
So it's a general phenomenon and I could go down the list.
I want to do that now.
I'll address one or two of these later on in other ways,
but basically send deal all the way down.
The good news of course is not just that we can do this classification,
but that we can write the right hand side of this table.
The purpose of the classification is precisely because for each of the
categories there is a generic approach to actually eliminating the damage to
fixing the problem.
The um,
you know,
when I say generic,
what I mean is that the world's definitely be differences at the details of how
we use this generic approach to address different examples within a given
category,
but only the details.
So if we look at cell loss,
of course you already know what the fix is.
It's called stem cell therapy.
That's exactly what stem cell therapy is.
We simply procure,
prepare preprogram if you like cells in the lab into the right state so that
when we inject them into the body,
they know what to do.
They know how to defer that to divide and differentiate to replace the cells
that the body is not replacing on its own.
Uh,
Parkinson's disease.
Coming back to that,
um,
you know,
that's exactly what's being done now.
Uh,
the first time this was attempted was 20 odd years ago and we were hopeless back
then at the pre programming staff.
We didn't know what to do to get stem cells into the right state before we
injected them.
And sure enough,
the um,
the process only gave any real benefit.
I'm very occasionally,
most people didn't benefit,
but the ones who did benefit didn't just benefit a little bit.
They will completely cured.
Just last year there was a paper that came out,
um,
celebrating the 25th anniversary of the first successful,
the first,
the first real responder of the first clinical trial in this area.
And this is the guy who was taken off all the other medications for Parkinson's
after a couple of years as had no,
no subsequent stem cell treatments or anything,
no Parkinson's disease,
25 years.
So this is real.
And now that we're much better at the pre programming,
if stem cells in the lab,
people are very much more confident that we can actually do this reproducibly
now.
So there are quite a lot of different clinical trials against Parkinson's that
are actually just getting going now or in,
in preparation.
Um,
and you know,
there's a lot of optimism.
So that's the kind of thing that we can expect when we really repair damage.
Now you may ask yourself,
well,
okay,
well stem cell therapy is,
you know,
very well respected area.
The right work is being done is already moving through to clinical trials.
Why did Aubrey de grey feel it's necessary to go around the world giving all
these talks and drumming up,
enthusiasm and so on.
And the answer is because the other six categories aren't telling you about
here.
Um,
March,
much less well appreciated.
That's why sensory research foundation exists.
In fact,
we exist because all of the other categories are just as important to cell loss.
But yet the ways to fix them,
uh,
either just,
you know,
hardly anyone understands that they could actually happen at all or else,
they're just not understood well enough.
They're not appreciated how important they are or whatever.
So we spent a lot of athletes and a lot of money trying to develop these things
at the early stage,
proof of concept level.
So as we can get them to the point where the rest of society and the rest of the
research community takes them seriously.
Now I won't draw your attention.
Before I go to the next slide,
I want to draw your attention to the bottom line here because you may be
thinking to yourself,
well hang on,
how does Aubrey know that this really isn't exhaustive classification and that
there isn't some category number eight and number nine that's been overlooked.
And of course it's a very important question and we definitely cannot say that
we are 100% know that there are no further categories we've been looking,
that's for sure.
And more than that,
I've been going out there and making trouble,
you know,
generally making a nuisance of myself.
I'm getting,
I'm encouraging my colleagues to come up with things that break this
classification,
things that fall outside of it.
And you know what,
I'm getting away with it.
I've been doing it for a long time now.
So of course that's only circumstantial evidence but it's really quite strong
circumstantial evidence that um,
that we seem to be on the right lines.
Not only that,
the approach is on the right hand side of this table,
all the various repair methodologies that we are focused on.
I've also not had to change over the past 15 years.
We have been pursuing them of course.
And some of them have,
we've made progress in all of them and some of them have become easier as a
result of Nice surprises like the development of new technologies like CRISPR
and induced pluripotent stem cells that have um,
shorten the timeline to development of these things.
But there have been no examples of bad surprises of cases where we find that
they saw that approach is not going to work because of this or that new
discovery.
So that's again,
really good news.
I'm going to give you a little bit of a feel for this at the level of the actual
bench work now and as I mentioned earlier,
of course they're not biologists so I don't want to get too heavy,
but I do want to make sure that you understand I'm not totally bullshitting you.
So,
um,
so let me talk a little bit about atherosclerosis.
Storage is of course is the number one killer in the western world and it
consists of the accumulation of fatty deposits in our major arteries which grow
and grow and eventually burst and cause heart attacks and strokes.
So we'd like that not to happen,
that's for sure.
Now,
the beginning of atherosclerosis is depicted on this slide here.
This is a micrograph of parts of a cell called a foam cell to one of the from
cell phone.
So it's a cell that used to be a perfectly healthy,
self-respecting white blood cell or macrophage.
That macrophage went into the artery wall with the goal of cleaning up detritus
that we're stuck there,
which just,
you know,
it just happens.
That's what,
that's one thing that macrophages do.
They're very good at it.
The detritus is mostly made of cholesterol.
It turns out,
and cholesterol,
you know,
gets a bad rap,
but it's a vital molecule.
The body needs a lot of it and macrophages know exactly what to do with
cholesterol.
They know how to reprocess and repackage it and export it so that it can be
reused.
That's all wonderful.
But unfortunately there is a small concentration of contaminant within this
detritus.
Most of that contaminant,
the master's is actually oxidation derivatives,
chemical changes,
chemically altered cholesterol that has become um,
clinically different and in various ways not amenable to processing by the
macrophage.
So instead of processing the macrophage,
processing the cholesterol,
this oxidized cholesterol poisons the macrophage and it gets like this,
the lysosomes,
this part of the cell,
which is very important in this processing business.
It becomes full of fat basically.
And then the rest of the self fell up with these globules of fat,
you can see them.
So that's the beginning of atherosclerosis from sales happen.
They get more and more of them.
They be that,
they start to basically get angry and the south around them get angry and more
macrophages come in to solve the problem,
but they can't.
So they become part of the problem.
And that's how atherosclerosis progressive.
So what can we do about this?
Well,
of course people have tried a bunch of stuff.
One approach is surgery.
Go in and ream out these arteries and try and get rid of this fatty stuff so
that it doesn't accumulate enough to,
uh,
to burst and courthouse stack.
And that's,
you know,
pretty crude really.
And it doesn't work terribly well.
The other alternatives that people have tried a lot,
it's statens startings of drugs which reduce the rate at which the body
synthesizes cholesterol.
And that kind of makes sense if you do that.
If you reduce the amount of cholesterol,
you're going to reduce the amount of oxidized cholesterol.
So you're going to slow down the,
um,
the poisoning of macrophages.
But,
and I mentioned earlier,
cholesterol,
these are rather important molecule we can't do without it.
So that only so much that you can push that kind of,
um,
Abrook and sure enough starting to have bad side effects.
What do we actually want to do?
Common Sense again,
what we actually want to do is go after the actual problematic reagent,
which is the oxidized cholesterol.
And in particular what we might like to do is give our macrophages the enhanced
ability to break down oxidized cholesterol.
They'll process it in just the same way that they can naturally process normal
cholesterol.
If we could give them an extra enzyme,
for example,
that just allowed them to degrade oxidized cholesterol,
then bang,
you know,
they wouldn't be poisoned by it anymore.
So that's exactly what we set out to do more than 10 years ago now.
Um,
we,
we decided to find another species which already had an enzyme to break down
oxidized cholesterol.
It turns out that it's fairly straightforward to find bacteria that can break
down more or less anything you like as long as it's organic.
And,
and this has actually become a really important,
um,
commercial,
uh,
and other,
it's called bio remediation.
This of course he's not a biomedical thing.
This is for environmental decontamination.
Do you find bacteria that can break down t and t for example?
Then you can just spray them over with our field that you want to build a
housing estate on and the t and t is going to go away and you'll be able to
build your housing estate.
This actually is done in the real world,
so great.
But our goal is not to spray bacteria into the body because that might have side
effects.
And our goal is to find these bacteria,
but then to identify the genes,
the enzymes that they have to allow them to break down this toxic molecule and
then put that gene into human cells modified in such a way that it still works
despite the various structural differences that exist between bacteria and
mammalian cells.
And he turned out to work.
So step one is pretty easy finding the bacteria.
Step two is also pretty easy.
Finding the genes that the bacteria have,
the give them the capacity to break down the stuff is that three isn't actually
really hard tweaking the Jane so that it still works in human cells.
But we managed it for years ago.
This is the key figure from the paper where we um,
where we reported this success.
Essentially what we're saying here is each group of bars is a different
concentration of the toxic molecule.
Seven Quito cholesterol,
which is a particular type of oxidized cholesterol.
And within each group what you've got is the right hand bar is our engineered
cells and all the others are what are called negative controls.
So for example,
self that don't have the enzyme or they've got the wrong enzyme or they've got
the right enzyme but it's not been modified so that it goes to the right part of
the sale,
for example.
And the height of the bar is simply the health of the cells,
the viability.
So the fact that the right hand bar in each of the groups is taller than the
ones to its left that tells you that for each of these various concentrations of
the toxin,
we are protecting the cells by introducing this gene.
And this is of course quite promising results and it's being taken forward now
into mouse models.
And we would hope that this will be a much more effective approach to stopping
people from getting heart attacks and strokes than anything that's around today.
So I'm going to address a few things that you might be thinking.
So first of all,
um,
some of you may have come across my work before actually hands up,
hands up.
Anyone who's actually seen the talk of what I've given him the pastor.
Right.
Can I get to the good [inaudible] all right.
Um,
so some of you might know that when I first started putting these ideas out
there,
a lot of people didn't think much of them.
A lot of paypal gave.
Um,
we're,
we're quite,
we're quite derogatory.
Um,
and that's kind of no surprise because the fact is,
as I've already emphasized,
I was bringing together a lot of new ideas that had never been brought into
gerontology before.
In fact,
you've just seen one which would never be even be brought into anything
biomedical before it was only used for environmental decontamination.
So there was a huge amount of education that had to occur.
I'm sure you appreciate that sciences are very balkanized fields that people
think they know what they need to know,
you know,
they know that they have a particular area of expertise that they're good at and
they think they know what's relevant to that and they won't really take the
trouble to learn very much about things that they don't think are relevant.
And it's pretty hard to break that down.
So it took,
I'm going to say the best part of a decade for me to actually get my colleagues
a predominance of my colleagues to the point where they actually understood that
what I was saying,
we've not complete nonsense,
but it worked.
I really did get that.
First of all,
we've published a lot,
you know,
we've actually got a lot of papers out there in the academic literature,
including in high profile journals,
demonstrating key proof of concept steps towards getting these things to work.
So that's one kind of,
you know,
um,
uh,
community recognition.
Then we've got an advisory board consisting of a large number of extremely high
profile world leading scientists in all the relevant areas.
These are not the kinds of people that publicly endorsed stuff,
that bullshit.
So this is actually quite important,
but bud was most important of all is that the idea is being reinvented by other
people.
Now.
So this paper came out four years ago and it's the identical same idea.
I mean,
they'd decided to divide it into nine categories instead of seven.
But it's exactly a divide and conquer damage repair approach here are there
corresponding fixes?
Their graphics are a bit better than mine were.
But the fact is,
you know,
it's identically the same idea.
And the difference is that this paper was written by grandees and it's being
cited literally still,
but once every two days.
This is probably the single most influential paper in the whole of Gerontology
as of now,
and it is identically the same idea that I put forward more than a decade
previously.
Now,
you know,
it would be nice if I were to get a bit more of the credit,
but that's really not what bothers me.
The fact is that this is now completely mainstream and Orthodox and any
misapprehension that you may have as a result of the kinds of things that
gerontologists we're often saying about these ideas 10 years ago should be
forgotten because there are no longer saying that this has now something totally
accepted.
Second thing is to do with the magnitude and the proximity of this work,
and this is something that I fell I do need to address,
especially with an audience like this because this is something that polarizes
opinion a huge amount.
First thing I want to say is people get terribly exercise about the idea of
living longer,
Bang,
scary,
you know,
and of course a large part of what they are basing that on is the idea that
living a lot longer,
my tile living a lot longer in the same state of health that we currently
associate with Olay,
which of course is considerably less fun than the state of health that we
currently associated with early adulthood.
So let me be perfectly clear,
the is zero chance,
zero chance that any of this work will ever deliver that kind of life extension.
The only way that we are ever going to get people living substantially longer is
by keeping them truly,
genuinely useful for substantially longer is always going to be risky to be
sick.
So do not worry about that.
The question though is how much longer,
I mean in a why medicine always has the side effect,
right?
After all,
most people die of being sick.
So if you can help people not to be sick,
you're on average going to have them live longer.
Make sense?
The question is how much longer?
And it turns out that the quite a,
so
the therapists that I've told you about so far,
I believe have a respectable chance of giving us an additional 30 years or so of
extra life.
And of course,
as I'm saying,
healthy life now,
that's a lot.
It's a lot more than what we can do today,
but it sure isn't immortality or any of the other words that the media tend to
like to associate with my work.
So what's the big deal?
You know,
that's great,
but so what,
you know people that aren't going to get second and old and dad as before,
right?
I mean we've already extended the average lifespan by more than 30 years in the
past hundred years.
So you know what's the big deal?
The big deal is the thing that was called longevity escape velocity,
which to a software engineer is a ridiculously straightforward concept.
It certainly is that these are rejuvenation therapies.
Therefore they will be applied to people who are already in,
let's say middle aid,
let's say 60 or 70 at the time that the therapy's arrive.
Those people will be rejuvenated such that they won't get back to being
biologically 60 until they're 90 because that's the 30 years I'm talking about.
But we've bought that time.
In that 30 years,
we've been able to improve the quality,
the comprehensiveness that convenience the costs,
but especially the comprehensiveness of the therapies so that the same people
are now 90 can be rejuvenated even though the damage that the bodies contain
will be the difficult damage that the original therapies don't work on.
Nevertheless,
some of it will be amenable to repair by the new therapy by let's call it sends
2.0 30 years down the road.
So all we've got to do is improve the comprehensiveness of these therapies by a
sufficient rate at an efficient rate to stay one step ahead of the problem and
the faintest analysis of what that rate actually would be will tell you that
it's tiny.
It's fastly lower than the rate that we always see in the incremental
improvements of technologies once the initial breakthrough has been made.
So longevity,
escape velocity is the reason why I believe that the first person to live to a
thousand there's probably less than 10 years younger van,
the first person to live to 115 and why the first cohort,
most of whom will live to a thousand if probably only 10 years younger than the
first cohort,
most of whom will live to 110 you know?
So these are,
these are obvious things,
but talk to biologists about this,
especially gerontologists they,
well,
almost all of them run away very,
very fast because first of all,
it's not science.
Of course he's not fucking science.
It's technology.
All right,
I knew that.
But that's,
that is also,
it's politically incendiary gerontologists where you know,
reputations to maintain and tenure to obtain and grant applications to submit.
They do not want to be associated with things that the public haven't been able
to get their heads around unless they sit in the public,
aren't very good at math and they're not very good at things like this.
So that is,
it's a very hard political sell right now.
But I believe that it's better to tell the truth about what we can expect from
anti aging medicine of the foreseeable future than to try to sweep it under the
carpet.
I believe that the right thing to do is to actually say,
look,
yes,
we are going to be able to keep people youthful indefinitely because we are
going to improve these therapies first and ask and to say yes.
That's a good thing and not to be cowardly about it.
Now the other thing to point out is that this is coming quite soon.
I believe that we have a 50 50 chance of guessing these technologies working
within about 20 years,
just long as there is enough funding for the really early stage research that's
happening right now.
Now,
of course I know perfectly well,
but this is pioneering technology and like any pioneering technology,
they timeframes are ridiculous.
The speculative,
there's certainly a 10% chance that we won't get there for a hundred years
because we'll hit problems that we haven't thought about yet,
but some of the whole lot,
you know what I mean?
50% chances,
quite enough to be worth fighting for.
Thinking about longevity escape velocity though is that even the,
it is a concept that gerontologists hate and the concept that the public doesn't
get and just kind of feels intuitively it can't be true.
Nevertheless,
it's only a matter of time before people do get it.
You know,
it's so simple that people are just going to get it and I believe that that's
probably going to happen within the next few years.
I believe that there's going to be a real sea change in real tipping point in
public attitudes,
public opinion,
public understanding of this whole field and it's going to happen soon.
And that's rather important to take into account because what it means is that
we have the responsibility of those of us who do have a bit of intelligence and
you've got understand this already.
We have the responsibility to act now in whatever way we can to minimize the the
turbulence.
You know,
the,
the sheer magnitude of the shit that's going to hit the fan.
When the world realizes all of this,
we have to try to figure out how to maximize the humanitarian benefit from all
of this to maximize the number of lives saved and thereby to get these
technologies out there as quickly as possible.
You know,
and,
and a lot of that revolves around anticipating these changes in public
attitudes.
Um,
let me explain why I say that
at the moment.
What do you talk to people about and you say,
how long do you want to live?
Would you want to live to 150?
Most people will say no.
If you ask them that question in an unadorned manner,
even if you ask them the questions,
do you want to live to 150 in a truly useful state of health?
They will still mostly say no largely because they won't take the question
seriously.
They weren't really believe that you mean what you say by the question.
That's how deep seated the,
an entrenched the belief in the inevitability of aging really is.
Which means that when people are forced to think about the consequences of truly
eliminating aging,
there's very,
very bad at it.
They will come up with this or that potential problem that might be created as a
consequence of fixing the problem we have today.
The problem of aging and then two things will happen.
Number one,
they will immediately presume that the problem with insoluble and he's got to be
far worse than the problem of aging.
And number two,
they will immediately switch their brains off and refused to consider the
possibility that we might have a way to solve this other problem too.
So for example,
almost every talk,
I guess people will come up even in almost every interview,
I guess people will come up and they'll say,
well,
we push all the people.
And you know,
I think giving perfectly simple answers to this question for God only knows how
long and nobody challenges the answers.
You know,
the standard answer,
the best answer is simply other technologies like renewable energy and
artificial meat and desalination and so on are going to be increasing the
carrying capacity of the planet far more rapidly than the population of the
planet will increase.
Therefore,
the,
the population stress that the planet is currently experiencing will diminish
whether we cure aging or not.
That's the obvious answer,
really obvious.
And no one ever says,
oh,
that doesn't,
that's true.
They just let it go in one ear and out the other and the following day they'll
come back and they'll still ask the same question.
It's extremely frustrating and you can probably talk.
Um,
and,
and it's the same with all the other nonsense.
I mean,
well,
what great example is that people will get this out of the population,
um,
concern and the same people in the next breath will say,
oh,
do are going to be for the rich.
I mean,
how the fuck can you not say that these things are mutually exclusive?
really?
So,
I mean,
you know,
it's very,
it's very frustrating as you can tell.
Um,
and you know what?
I mean,
last I heard dictator was fairly high on the league table of risky jobs.
You know,
that most people don't really die of aging when they anyway.
And you know,
I mean boredom.
You know what my friend Brian Kennedy's had a good one on that.
He said,
well look,
if I've got the choice of getting Alzheimer's when I'm 80 or being bored when
I'm 150,
I think I know which one I'm going to choose.
Um,
and uh,
you know,
there's a sense of proportion just does not come into the way that people
address these questions.
It's absolutely embarrassing.
So obviously I don't have much time for this nonsense.
I am.
I feel that it's important to go out there and be positive and say to people,
listen,
for Christ's sake,
do you want to get Alzheimer's?
Do you want anyone else to get Alzheimer's?
It's cancer.
I said,
no you don't.
So it's consider a world in which nobody does get those things.
That would be quite nice,
wouldn't it?
And you'd have a situation where the elderly were still able bodied and they
were able to contribute well to society.
So everybody will be ridiculously more prosperous and they will have the energy
to explore novelty.
So they would not get bored any more than a young person gets bored when they're
bored.
You there go and find something new to do,
you know,
Jesus.
So that's enough of the ranch.
I'll come back to another ranch shortly,
but before I do that,
let me just actually talk a bit about the,
um,
about the spinoffs that we're doing because we started out as a nonprofit,
many years ago now.
And the reason we did was because the word that we were doing was so early stage
that there was no way it was investible even in,
even in Silicon Valley where obviously we've got a nicely high density of
visionary investors.
Um,
but that's changed over the past few years.
We've been able to push some things far enough along in terms of proof of
concept that we have been able to spend them out.
Don't just give you a few examples.
This is a company,
it's right so far about five or five and a half million dollars.
Um,
it's looking mainly at macular degeneration.
The number one cause of blindness in the elderly actually pursuing very much the
same approach to it that I already outlined in relation to atherosclerosis.
Though in this case the target is not oxidized cholesterol.
It's something completely different.
Um,
so that's pretty good news.
Another example is a company came out of Texas,
so we funded all surface ever.
Really is,
and this is to do with what's called amyloidosis,
which turns out to be a very important reason why the extreme elderly people
over the age of 100 and 510 dark.
This is what they,
this is what most of them die off.
Um,
we've got a company called Aira Ghost,
which was started by the person who used to be our chief operating officer.
It's working on Oregon cryo preservation and have on a new method for freezing
organs in such a way as to basically do no damage to them by crystallization or
anything like that so that you can warm them up again and stick them into
another person.
And this is something that has been quite a holy grail of organ transplantation
for a long time,
but this group have now figured out how to do it.
And again,
this is,
you know,
they've been,
they've received only seed money so far,
but they are moving forward very rapidly.
Now another example is a company called ocean,
which is looking at senescent cells,
so less themselves,
the type of cell that gets into an aberrant state and does more harm than good,
but it doesn't go away.
And this is a way of getting rid of them.
It's a bit more controllable than the drugs you may have heard about that and
that other companies are looking for.
Now,
um,
I know that you know,
this actually is,
we're just around the corner.
We are headquartered three miles,
two miles from here.
I cycled here today.
So the fact is you guys,
yourselves could make a difference and any of you want to come and visit,
you're always very welcome.
You can,
I'll give you my email address at the end of the talk.
You can get in touch through the people here who are already in contact with us
and already donating.
I mentioned the effect of altruism at the beginning of the talk.
I'm going to mention it again.
That number I've got on this slide.
$1 per life is a fairly conservative estimate.
You can do these numbers.
You can just say,
well,
okay,
look how much is the current shorter given money,
slowing things down,
and of course that's subjective,
but my current estimate is that probably about 10 years,
but we could speed up the defeat of aging,
the achievement of longevity,
escape velocity by about a decade just by getting this work done at a speed that
is not limited by financial resources.
So how much financial resources to do that,
we just need one more did it on a budget.
That still means we'd be looking at 1% of CALICO's budget.
We need about 40 million a year,
40 million.
I mean,
that's a tiny amount and we could go,
I'm going to say three times faster in the initial few years anyway,
and I think,
yeah,
we could talk a decade off the time involved.
So we're talking about half a billion lives.
That's about about how many people die of aging in the decade.
And we're talking roughly 40 or $50 million a year for 10 years.
So it comes out around a dollar per life.
And if you do that same calculation for anything else,
you know,
mosquito nets,
whatever you like,
you don't get that number,
you get a number that's much larger in terms of number of dollars per life.
And that's of course,
just presuming that the life is the same,
which of course it isn't because we're,
what we should really be calculating is the number of additional healthy life
years,
which is essentially indefinite.
In the case of defeating aging,
where it's definitely not indefinite for anything else.
Keep wanting is the last line,
the number of dollars per life it's going to go up as time goes on.
The earliest stages of this work are always the time when you can make the most
difference with a given amount of financial backing.
So now is the time when you can make the most difference.
This isn't the book I wrote,
which there is one leftover over on the,
over on the table over there.
Um,
but obviously we're perfectly happy to provide more of them.
I wrote this about 10 years ago and that might suggest to you that it's out of
date.
Uh,
but luckily even though the has been huge amount of progress over the past
several years,
the progress is in question has been very mark what we expected it to be,
what we've predicted it would be.
As I mentioned at the beginning,
no,
we haven't had any nasty surprises.
So in that sense,
the science is still very much what it should be and I very much recommend it.
It's written for non specialists.
In other words,
it doesn't have any real,
you know,
rely on phone,
biological jargon.
But at the same time it is pretty dense.
You won't get through it in one sitting.
I'll stop there.
Thank you.
I'm happy to answer questions.
I don't know whether people can just shout or whether the microphone for the
recording or what.
Hi,
my name is Evan.
Thank you.
Great Talk.
Uh,
just a quick question on the fundraising piece.
Like am I,
my sense is that there is a lot of money out of there for if you had Brandon for
like cancer research or Alzheimer Research,
you know,
they're,
there might be other,
I was how well,
how has,
you know,
what are your thoughts on just maybe rebranding and going after different
avenues there?
So the,
um,
the,
the issue that really is we have to do two things.
On the one hand,
yes,
we absolutely have to get people to understand that this is a medical problem
and this is not something in the stratosphere as I mentioned at the beginning.
But on the other hand,
we also have to demonstrate that the approach that we want to take,
which is substantially different from what other people are taking is much more
likely to succeed.
If we talk,
for example,
about Alzheimer's,
then we started out in a position where we are competing with the established
anti Alzheimer's community and people are going to say,
well look,
if this is worth doing and surely the Alzheimer's Association is going to be
funding it already and therefore since the Antarctic must not be worth doing.
So it's got,
it's circular.
But what it means is that we have to start off by telling it like it is in terms
of the taxonomy of sickness and say,
listen,
think about aging in a new way and then break that down into what is common
sense,
what makes sense to do about it?
Well,
the question over here.
Yes.
So how about New Korea genomic mutations in stealth,
Andrea mutations.
I mean,
that goes as a snowbird,
right?
But in the end,
that's hard drives cancer,
right?
Uh,
you want to about the effect of,
okay,
what's the Mitochondria of the attractions are one of our seven strand.
And even though unlike the other ground where I've gotten a lot of mutations
cannot definitively be linked to any particular pathology of old age in the same
way that for example,
molecular wave products can be linked to atherosclerosis.
Uh,
nevertheless,
there's plenty of circumstantial evidence that said we need to fix them.
And so what we're doing is putting backup copies of the mitochondrial DNA,
the nucleus modify.
Why did it works?
This is an idea that were first put forward in the 1980s.
People basically gave up on it and inside it was too hard.
We decided they'd given up too easily.
We were right.
It took us 10 years to prove it.
But we had a paper out a year ago,
which were the great breakthrough compared to anything that had been achieved so
far.
And we are,
we're chugging along.
We're going to get there now.
So that's good if nucleotide and different matter entirely.
So in one sense,
of course we're very much tackling those in the sense that one of our other
strands,
it's cancer.
We don't want cells that divide when they shouldn't.
And we have a particular approach to going about cancer and maybe other brokers
will work.
The question then is,
if we don't have to worry about cancer,
if we've got a fix for cancer,
then do nuclear mutations still matter?
And it looks very much as though they'd done the,
the ads that we're looking at it is to say,
well look,
one cell can kill you if it gets the wrong constellation of mutations.
It's death by dividing and dividing and becoming a cancer.
Whereas anything else,
anything that does not have to do with the cell cycle,
you've got to have that mutation happen.
You know,
a lot of different cells in the same tissue in order for it to have any
phenotypic consequences and the actual bad effects.
And that isn't going to happen.
And it's the same machinery that defends the fan DNA repair and maintenance
machinery that defends against both outcome.
So essentially what I,
I've called this protagonistic lower trophy.
I could explain the reason for that terminology if you like.
But the point is that the imperative not to die of cancer before we've
reproduced,
um,
has forced evolution to develop DNA repair and maintenance machinery.
That's so good that it's unnecessarily good for every other purpose.
And so we just don't get any consequences of mutations of other kinds until much
more than a currently normal lifespan.
Now that may sound a little abstract and theoretical and maybe it's not
completely worded side.
So obviously we would like to have data that actually confirms this,
but that seems,
it seems to me exactly what we have.
People who've done the experiments looking at the rate at which mutations
accumulate in,
um,
in mammals.
And it's looking okay during growth during,
until up to adulthood.
The reason the cumulation of mutation load in every tissue,
a respectable for special,
right?
But once an animal mouse reaches adulthood,
in most issues,
there's nothing any further increases undetectable.
And of course it was no increase in the company and the consequence of an
increased.
So,
so that's pretty good.
Now again,
it's not worth sides.
It could be other types of mutation or epic mutations can just to the
decorations of DNA.
And we've actually spent a bit of money on that,
on that question,
trying to actually get a definitive answer to whether that matters.
Haven't really got a definitive answer yet,
but insofar as we have an answer at all,
it looks to be coming out the same way.
I have a question,
kind of a bigger picture question.
So when you're talking about pathology and not looking at pathologies,
um,
so I'm thinking like cancer for example.
What's the difference between not curing cancer but somehow rejuvenating,
um,
cells that are splitting and so like the big vision,
is that like a top up rejuvinating preventative injection once every year or
something to keep people or is it actually treating pathologies once they occur?
Well,
a bit of both really.
So the idea is certainly to identify damage before it if symptomatic before it
reaches the point of being bad for you.
So in the case of cancer,
that basically means identifying cells that have got most of the mutations that
they,
that you don't want them to have.
And then dividing when they shouldn't and let just get the immune system and
fell on.
So identifying sort of aberrant in one way or another,
not actually our approach to fixing cancer involves essentially putting a time
bomb in that that stops the cancer from dividing,
um,
indefinitely essentially causes the ends of the chromosomes to get shorter so
that eventually the fell basically divides itself into oblivion by virtue of
having an [inaudible] essentially joined together.
Um,
but there are other possibilities,
especially enhancing the immune system is a big fashionable area right now.
That may very well be a good answer as well.
So,
um,
so,
so the fairest way to go about it,
but yes,
the idea is to go after the damage,
the accumulating damage,
not necessarily the pathology itself.
However,
and this is not just for cancer,
but elsewhere as well.
It may also end up being a good thing to go after them both together I think go
after the damage and the pathology.
I mentioned earlier that the fundamental reason why the geriatrics approach
doesn't work is because the cause of the pathologies,
the damage is continuing to accumulate.
So what that means is this,
you can repair the damage and stuff it from continuing to accumulate.
Then maybe some of the pathologies will just automatically resolve in their own
rights on their own,
but maybe not.
But still it means that the straightforward geriatric therapies that go off to
the pathology is we'll have a much better chance against those pathologies and
they would normally have.
Yup.
Got It.
Hey,
there's quite a good chance that we'll get this,
um,
uh,
like technologist working near future.
Uh,
like would you recommend any or like,
um,
existing methods to kind of buy us like more years to kind of,
to actually reach this point?
People think I'm joking when I give their farm for,
but the fact is the only thing you can do if,
give me large amount of money,
the fact is there's nothing yet that works.
I mean,
of course there are obvious things like don't smoke,
don't get theory or flee overweight,
but nothing,
there's nothing new.
No one's come up with anything that gave her more than more than a very
negligible amount at Beth of both burn with the bell health with what we can do
today.
So we are absolutely reliant on still being around in time for the technology
and for that don't yet exist.
So I wanted to kind of ask kind of a speculative question.
Imagine still thought experiment that these technologies do come to fruition.
We've massively improved human lifespan,
even reaching longevity,
escape velocity.
How do you see that affecting the evolution of the human species to some of
these methods where introducing themselves with modified genes that become a
mechanism of pollution?
What,
what happened?
Yeah,
that's the answer.
So basically people say,
well,
oh well we have a,
a bit won't have so many kids.
Therefore evolution will flow down complete nonsense.
Actually what's going to happen is the opposite of evolution will vary greatly
speed up,
because a lot of the technologies that we're going to be developing that will
allow us to implement these rejuvenation therapies will be ones that involve
manipulating the genomes of people who are already alive.
So we'll be able to translate the genetic composition of paper without any of
this terribly time consuming,
consuming reproduction nonsense.
I think we'll be able to keep like all people evolving at the same rate.
Wow.
Of course.
It depends what you mean by right.
Because people will be going in different directions,
you know,
different people will have different modification.
Thinking especially about the things that really affect success of like
intelligence is probably the most important.
Again,
you don't know.
I mean,
okay.
So of course there we've got the issue that we haven't the faintest idea what
James actually really confer intelligence in the first place.
Um,
so you know,
that's a,
that's a whole different questions.
And to be honest,
I haven't put much thought into that and I don't think it's my job.
Can you tell me just briefly about what's been done for a telemetric
degeneration?
Right.
So this goes back to the question though of about cam through a moment ago.
So wellness.
So for those of you who don't know,
when cells divide the end of the chromosomes,
which are called the telomeres get shorter.
This is an intrinsic,
absolutely irrevocable property of the way that DNA has replicated.
And in order to compensate for that,
we have an enzyme called telomerase,
which sticks now noncoding random,
well not random but specifically,
but very simple sequences of DNA on the end of the chromosomes to um,
to counteract the shortening that would be occur.
And some people think that is important for us to enhance the activity of this
enzyme telomerase.
And in order to combat aging,
because cells in older people have obviously divided more often and therefore
they will have shorter telomeres.
The counter to that argument is that actually most of our cells don't divide
very often at all and they not often leaving enough in a normal lifetime to get
to the point where their telomeres problematically short.
And furthermore,
that the cells that do divide rather often already do express enough of this
enzyme telomerase to compensate and make sure that the two of them only get
shorter at what seems to be a manager of all right.
However,
there's still controversy about this.
There are certain reasons to believe that in some aspect of the body,
especially the immune system,
this phenomenon which is called replicative Senescence,
we've still them,
I was getting too short,
could be a,
it could be a real thing,
a real,
a real contributor to ill health.
So we want to do stimulation of telomerase and indeed the Ronna message drugs
especially that seem to have that effect and those guys are improving all the
time.
So That's interesting.
But we always have to be,
be aware that cancer cells divide when we don't want them to and they do it
precisely by elevating their level of synthesis,
that level of expression of telomerase.
So they are the NFL w who fill on maybe the question we would like to suppress
now.
Um,
if we come up with a method for eliminating cancer that doesn't involve telomere
shortening,
let's say just to do with the immune system and it works really,
really,
really well,
then we're Humphrey.
Absolutely.
It will make sense to look pretty hard as well as to stimulate telomerase and
thereby perhaps rejuvenate the immune system and maybe other cell types that
might be experiencing some level of replicative senescence.
Uh,
however it could be that we will end up wanting to go.
The other way that we will find that the suppression of telomerase activity,
it's the only really solid,
really ironclad way to eliminate cancer and that was just all live with the side
effects of which will actually be worse than what we might see is a day in
which,
for example,
the stem cells of the blood can no longer divided indefinitely until we ended up
with anemia and so on.
The reason why I say we could live with that is because the way in which we
could fix those side effect is actually conceptually fairly straight forward.
Namely stem cell therapy.
There's only a very small number of stem cell pools that are actually dividing
often enough for this to be a problem.
The blood is one of course,
the Epidermis,
the outer layer of the skin,
the inner,
the inner linings of guts and probably the lung.
Those are really the only ones that massive.
And so we'd been looking quite hard.
The idea of doing stem cell therapies on all of those with cells that are unable
to make telomerase and therefore are protected against becoming properly
cancerous.
That's the kind of where we think about
next.
They've got the mic.
Sorry.
Okay.
This is,
I'm just,
you know,
maybe a little bit of a cipher,
but you are at Google.
Um,
have you thought about your competition being silicon?
I.
E.
We're just going to upload our consciousness to a computer at some point.
You know,
I mean if it works then you know,
so much the better.
But at this point it's still looked pretty hard.
I mean,
if,
if we're lucky,
if we do end up being able to develop really good,
um,
we can be through interfacing,
still allow a really high fidelity training of the next time we'll Brian from an
internal one from it,
from a natural one.
So on,
then we could be talking something realistic,
but at the moment it seems to be a long way off.
Following up on that,
I'm also a huge site by fan.
I was wondering if it's possible to use your research for long distance space
travel for NASA.
Oh sure.
Of course.
I mean the thing about longest suspension travel,
if it takes a long time and um,
you might not want to be awake all that time if,
if,
if you,
if your big thing is to just the stars,
maybe you prefer to be quiet reserved.
I'm up for that too.
But um,
yeah,
personally happy down here.
Yep.
Okay.
I'm sorry.
There is a 2015 article in some magazine or the head researcher says Elizabeth
Blackburn talking about the shortening of Tim or link and their observation is
that that's not the driving factor in the rate of aging and each cells,
uh,
that it's more related to [inaudible] activity.
Is this,
you kind of covered this in your question,
your answer a couple of times ago,
but,
um,
does that,
uh,
I mean,
does taking that into account all to your team or thread or anything?
Yeah,
no
Nobel prize for this work on telomerase a long time ago.
Um,
she's obviously a very prominent researcher in this area.
You see,
definitely very interested in the role that telomere shortening could have in an
aging.
Um,
most of what she'd actually been able to report more on the level of correlation
and causation.
Um,
you know,
for example,
that people who have suffered a lot of stress tend to have shorter telomeres.
We don't know which way around it went.
Um,
and I think that that,
uh,
but,
um,
but yeah,
I mean like be kind of what I said.
Are we running out of time?
Okay.
Yeah.
I have a question about a diet.
Um,
so basically,
um,
earlier you mentioned that you can use a status too.
Um,
I think this is basically to reduce the cholesterol in the blood,
but a,
I believe it is a at least two research sites that have quite strong about
reducing the incidents of attra sclerosis just by changing the Diet and uh,
it does not have the side effects that a student has and also increases all
course.
Oh,
decreases outcomes,
mortality.
So basically I think what was earlier claimed that one cannot change the life
expectancy a currently is not true,
but I'm not saying it's not the age related stuff,
but it's the stuff that's in your third column there which can actually be
addressed.
We're very careful with their studies,
so sure if Claire,
that atherosclerosis is as the seed of western diet,
it's very much more prevalent now than it used to be.
Um,
but if you look at the actual life expectancy fee aspect,
then,
if not very encouraging.
If we didn't get it,
if we have completely eliminated all heart attacks and stroke,
then we only live about five years longer.
If we 100% eliminated.
But,
and of course they've kind of to,
I don't by any means at 100% eliminated.
So we're still talking a very small amount of difference in terms of life
expected.
Yeah.
Yup.
All right.
Thanks very much everybody.
[inaudible].